SCHEIFELE OF THE WINNIPEG JETS
TO START
BLAKE WHEELER JETS CAPTAIN GAME
15 GOALS, 27 SCORING YANNI GOUR.
SCHMIDT IN CONTROL.
HE'LL DELIVER A PASS FOR AND IS
THE BY VINCE
DUNN WHO SETS UP MORGAN GEEKIE
AND THE KRAKEN CAN'T GET IT COR
IT SEEMED LIKE EVERY TIME
SEATTLE HAD THE PUCK THEY WERE
ALL OVER THEM, STICK CHECK,
STICK LIFT. DALLAS STARS, SAN
INSIDE THE BLUE LINE ON YOUR
DEFENSIVE AND IT
BACK FOR DUNN, WILL THINK TWICE
ABOUT HIS
SHOTS ARE 5-2, JETS.
OUT TO CENTER.
STRETCH PASS, BNCHANGE.
>> J.T.: BEAULIEU.
WHO HAS TIME TO BREAK IT OUT.
WHICH HE WILL.
GOOD ELEVATION BY JARED McCA
JARNKROK.
HE'LL GET IT BACK.
HELPED OUT BY TANEV MONEY, BRAN
TANEV, NOW ADAM LARSSON,
ACTIVATING OVER THE LINE, DROP
GETS THE STICK TANGLED
REBOUND.
EHLERS.
BACK TO THE SUPPORTED IT.
MORGAN GEEKIE GETS THE HAND
NET.
YOU HAVE DONATO STANDING  IN
FRONT.
GETTING SHIFT ON THE PUCK,
TRYING FIND THE OVER.
JANSEN HARKINS.
PASS BROKEN UP CHANCES.
PUCKS ARE GETTING
AND MARK SCHEIFELE FOR WINNIPEG
13:05 LEFT IN THE
SHOVED JOHANSSON.
IN THE ZONE.
ON THE
KYLE CONNOR.
AND BLAKE WHEELER FOR PAUL
KYLE CONNOR, SCORES.
AGAIN, LEFT
BUT THEN YOU SEE CONNOR
INTERRUPTED.
DONSKOI WIDE.
HE WAS FORCED BY THE AGAIN,
McCANN, DUNN, HAMMERS ONE,
PICK THIS
PENALTY KILL, STARTS WITH
WINNING THE FACEOFF, GETTING
PUCKS
HE SCORE!
GO IN ON THAT SHORT BREAK AND
KID'S A